everyone um yeah so I'm going to tell
you about attention today this work
joint work with Xiao song from Adobe uh
okay so what is
attention well attention is a technical
backbone behind uh a lot of modern
machine learning models um it's
especially used in you know recent
popular large language models like
Transformer BT gp4 and so on like the
the paper that introduced Transformer
was called attention is all you need
was talking about how how important
attention is uh roughly at a very high
level in attention you're given as input
matrices that describe T tokens or words
and the goal is to find correlations
between them in something called an
attention Matrix uh so that you can
figure out which of them are important
in the context of of the sentences
you're dealing with okay this is what
attention is but uh today I don't really
want to tell you about like theer of
Transformer models or why attention is
defined exactly how it is or you know
why is chat GPT so popular or so on I
want to tell you about an algorithm's
question which is how quickly can we
perform attention so let me start again
and tell you what is the algorithms
problem I'm going to tell you about it
today okay so in in attention the
algorithms problem you're given us input
three matrices they're called they're
usually like called the query key and
value matrices but they're I'll call
them qk and V and they're n by D
matrices where today let's think of d as
like a lot smaller than n like log n um
so in terms of these we Define this
important n byn Matrix called the
attention Matrix and it's defined like
this you multiply Q times K transpose so
you get a low rank n byn Matrix uh you
divide all the entries by D to to
rescale it but then you entrywise
exponentiate all the entries of the
Matrix this is sometimes called soft Max
attention you're you're like doing a
soft Max to the entries so you get this
attention Matrix a and then there's
there's one more important Matrix D
which is a diagonal matrix where you you
multiply a by the all ones Vector so you
get like the row sums of a uh and then
you think about multiplying D inverse
times a so this is like normalizing a so
that all its row sums are one so you can
think of the rows as like a probability
distribution okay so these are the
ingredients and then in the in the atten
problem the goal is to Output D inverse
time a time the last uh Matrix V which
is again an N by D Matrix so this is
this is the problem I want to tell you
about today and and usually it's not you
know necessary to exactly compute this
usually it's okay to approximate it
somehow I'll Focus today on like
Infinity Norm errors so like we want to
entry-wise approximation to this we want
um all the entries to be within Epsilon
like one over poly and uh additive error
of what they're supposed to be okay so
this this is the attention question and
then you can ask how quickly can we do
this well the kind of straightforward
algorithm where you just work through
all the definitions takes about n squar
time like you first multiply Q times K
transpose which gives you an N byn
Matrix you can do about n Square time
you entrywise exponentiate an N squ time
you multiply by all On's Vector in n s
time you multiply by V in about n Square
time if you just straightforwardly do
all these things each step takes about N
squared time okay on the other hand this
is a problem where the input and output
sizes are a lot smaller than n squ like
we're the input and outputs are just n
byd matrices which are like size n log n
so you could in principle hope to do a
lot faster than this um but on the other
hand you know this this uh attention
matrix it's really an N byn Matrix that
has n squ entries and like right in the
middle of the definition where entrywise
exponentiating it so in order to hope to
do faster than n squ time we really have
to do something that like implicitly
makes use of the Matrix a and doesn't
like actually compute most of the
entries of a or something like that okay
so in this talk I want to tell you about
algorithms and lower bounds for this
problem and what I'll show you is that
basically how quickly whether or not you
can you can speed this trivial algorithm
up and and do it faster than n squ time
depends on how big the entry of the Q K
and V input matrices are okay so here's
more specifically our results and
throughout a lot of the talk I'll put
this blue box here to remind you what
the definition of the question is okay
so so so so our main result is that how
quickly you can perform this attention
computation critically depends on the
magnitude of the entries of the input
matrices so let me call that magnitude B
so B is some number and we're we're
promised that all three of q k and and V
their entries have magnitude at most B
okay so we have two results uh the first
is uh is a new algorithm that says if B
is is less than square root of log n
okay so there's this threshold square
root of log n and if B is less than that
then there's actually a very fast nearly
linear time algorithm for this problem
you can do way way faster than N squared
time you can get all the way down to n
to the one plus little o of one almost
almost linear time in the in the input
size and our second result is a lower
bound that if B is bigger than this if B
is even just some big constant times
square root of log n then there's no
algorithm that runs in truly sub
quadratic time n to the 2 minus Delta
for any constant Delta assuming the
strong exponential time hypothesis from
fine grain complexity so there's really
a very sharp threshold here where if if
B is less than square root log n you can
solve it as fast as you could hope for
and if B becomes bigger than square root
of log in suddenly uh you can't
basically can't beat the trivial
algorithm for the problem um and you all
mention okay so there there's there's
been previous like experimental work
showing that uh techniques that that
make these matrices have smaller entries
uh are can actually lead to faster
algorithms like techniques like
quantization like rounding or hashing
techniques like low degree
approximations that I'll talk about more
later uh have actually led to fast
algorithms in practice so maybe our
theoretical result helps to explain this
type of thing yeah I'm just surprised
that the inry size matter so much kind
of just scale it up and down or is it
aspect Rao or uh yeah it's it's like
a like the yeah the entry sizeer yeah
yeah you'll see soon yeah the
the basically when the entry size gets
bigger the the relative ratio of entries
the attention Matrix gets very large and
this ends up being very important yeah
yes I think this is under the assumption
that D diens yeah that's
right how fast do this uh yeah very
quick so often you can depending on
exactly what you want you can use like
dimensionality reduction to kind of
assume it's sorry question oh sorry the
question is how is important is this
Dimension is that the dimension is dlog
in
uh it yeah it ends up being we'll see
pretty important for especially for the
algorithm we're really going to use this
uh like if the dimension is a even like
log in to the 1.5 things are really
going to break um but often depending on
the details you can do something like
dimensionality reduction to kind of
assume your dimension not exactly but
but I it seems to be a a situation that
comes up pretty often for this yeah and
in
this just one entry is huge is
uh you need a lot of the entries to be
big yeah yeah like about half the
entries are big yeah and about half the
entries are zero
basically yeah yes is the entrywise
approximation guarantee really important
for applications or or like how does
connect kind of with the
motivation uh that's a great question so
so the short answer is I'm I'm not
really the best person to ask that but
the these these papers at least talk
quite a bit about how that you can like
especially this one on quantization sort
of uh replaces the the coefficients with
smaller ones and shows that like the
answer you get at the end doesn't seem
to change too much but uh yeah it's it's
kind of there's kind of a trade-off here
between you would want bigger entries in
order to have a more expressive learning
model but you need smaller entries in
order to do the pro solve the problem
faster
okay
um so okay so in the rest of the talk my
goal is to show you the proofs of both
of these and especially focus on where
this square root of log n is going to
come from so hopefully that'll answer
your questions about it um so let me
tell you about the the high level idea
of what we do and this is the high I
think I think this is sort of not the
high level idea of our algorithms but
the high level idea of how Xiao and I
came up with our algorithms okay and
it's to take advantage of the similarity
between this attention problem and
another problem called gausian kernel
density estimation so here's again the
definition of the attention problem and
and there's a really similar problem
many of you probably seen before called
batch gausian kernel density estimation
which is very very similar you think of
a as like the kernel Matrix instead of
the attention Matrix um you no longer
have this this D rescaling diagonal
matrix here um and then you just output
a * V instead of the rescaling of a * V
okay this is yeah when you when you
think about what this problem is you can
you can write it in exactly the same
kind of way it looks very very similar
right uh and gausian kernel density
estimation is very well studied I think
there are even at least two other talks
in this Workshop that are going to talk
about kernel density estimation so uh
our approach is to show that a lot of
the techniques from the fine grain
complexity of Kernel density estimation
can also be modified to work for this
attention problem so another way you can
think about my talk is kind of giving a
like a survey of of techniques in the
fine grain complexity of Kernel density
estimation and then modifying them a
little bit to work in this situation
also yeah in the KD P you kind of need a
minus sign right that's kind of where
the hardness is coming from there's like
a minus and the exponent yeah but the
well you can negate the matrices to also
get a minus sign yeah the the matrices
we can have positive and negative matri
yeah okay so okay so that's our H so let
me tell you uh in more detail about the
the technical ideas and then the rest of
the talk is going to be about going into
even more details about these okay so
for the lower bound we're going to use a
tension computation to solve the
approximate closest pair problem um so
this is a problem you know you're given
as a bunch input of of points in L
dimensions and you want to find
approximately the closest pair of them
there's a really nice result by avad
Rubenstein fir a few years ago that
showed that this problem requires
roughly quadratic time assuming the
strong exponential time hypothesis so
we're going to reduce from closest pair
to this attention and and since closest
pair needs nend squared time attention
is also going to need N squared time um
and this is an approach that uh I think
the I think the first one to use this
approach was this nice paper by backer
indick and Schmidt from 2017 uh where
they applied it to Kernel density
estimation and it's been since used for
lots of Kernel density estimation
problems even there's even a recent work
that applied it to attention to get some
fine grain lower bound from attention
with uh in it sort of a different
parameter setting but it's a it's a I
think a popular approach now and we're
going to apply it here also um and then
the algorithm I'm going to use I think
my my favorite algorithmic technique
which is the polinomial method uh
which has also been used for KD before
like um if you're familiar with fast
multiple methods they critically use
loow degree polinomial approximations
right in the middle of them um H but
we're specifically going to use like a a
more recent approach to to using
polinomial in a in a slightly different
way for this type of problem and uh
we're going to make use of actually
quite recent uh new upper bounds on pols
to approximate exponential which is
going to
play okay that's the plan I'm going to
tell you about these things uh and I'll
mention that other there are other
popular techniques from kernel density
estimation like locality sensitive
hashing and so on these have also been
previously applied to attention we're
not like the first to notice that
attention looks like kernel density
estimation uh but these types of
techniques usually you you like if the
dimension is higher than log in like
people are asking about then hashing is
more effective than than just
okay so here's the outline I'll start by
telling you about the lower bound and
then I'll tell you about the algorithm
and then uh finally I'll tell you about
polinomial approximations for
exponentials which is like the technical
power house behind the
algorithm
okay so so again our plan is we're going
to reduce from the approximate closest
pair problem to the attention problem so
let me remind you what is the 1 plus
Epsilon approximate Hing closest pair
problem so this problem you're given as
input NX vectors and NY vectors uh
there're 01 vectors of Dimension D like
order log n and you're also given some
threshold T usually think of t as some
constant that's between zero and
one and the goal is to distinguish
between two cases okay in case one uh
there exists a close pair there exists
an i and J such that the IX vector and
the J y Vector have Hamming distance at
most T times the dimension and case two
is that they're all they're all 1 plus
Epsilon far from this for all the pairs
of an X vector and a y Vector their
distance is at least 1 plus Epsilon * T
* think of Epsilon and T are both both
small constants here um so how quickly
can we solve this okay you know again
this straightforward algorithm is
quadratic time uh using like standard
nearest neighbor search tools you can
like locality sensitive hashing you can
solve it in sub quadratic time like n
the 2 minus order Epsilon um the fastest
algorithm runs in this time n the two
minus the cube root of Epsilon so if
you're thinking Epsilon is like a small
number less than one then cube root of
Epsilon is bigger than Epsilon and then
you're subtracting it away in the
exponent so this is a faster algorithm
than the lsh one okay this is the the
fastest known algorithm and actually
this algorithm uses the polinomial
method so this maybe gives some some
insight into why the polinomial method
should be helpful for attention we like
reducing closest pair to attention and
the fastest algorithm for closest pair
uses polinomial method so maybe this
gives a hint that polinomial method
should also be helpful for the attention
problem okay um and then then the the
key fact about this problem we'll use is
this hardness result by avad who showed
that uh assuming the strong exponential
time hypothesis uh basically for any
Delta in the exponent there exists an
Epsilon so that you can't do 1 plus
Epsilon approximate Hing closest pair in
time n to the 2us Delta so the Delta
ends up being you know something smaller
than this or bigger rather than this
this okay you can think of this this
problem uh as Epsilon gets small enough
really requires pretty much quadratic
time okay so let me first do one uh
trick which is I'm going to convert from
closest pair to a a different related
problem maximum like approximate maximum
in our product which is going to be
helpful because attention you know
involves lots of inner products in the
attention Matrix okay so given as input
these NX vectors and NY vectors uh so
let me Define some things so for for a
given one of the X vectors which is a
dimension d01 Vector uh so first I'm
going to let x i with a bar on top be
the bit wise complement so that the
entries that were ones are zeros and the
entries that were zeros or ones uh and
then I'm going to let X Prime be the
concatenation of X and its complement
okay so this is a vector of length 2D
now still of zeros and ones uh but it
has some nice properties first is that
now x i Prime it's half his entries are
ones and half its entries are zeros
because you match each entry with its
complement entry in the second half um
and also now the distance between the
vectors before you can write in terms of
the inner products of these new vectors
so like uh you can check that the
distance between the prime vectors is
twice the distance between the original
vectors the distance between the
complements is the same um and the
distance between the prime vectors you
can write it as the number of ones in X
prime plus the number of ones in y Prime
minus twice their inner product this is
like counting uh we're like counting how
many entries have a one in one of them
and a zero in the other so this is like
the number of ones in the first plus the
number of ones in the second plus we
subtract away two times the number of
entries where they both have a one then
that count the number of entries where
exactly one of them has a one um and
because they're both half ones and zeros
this is two 2D minus twice the inner
product um so using this trick uh our
goal for this problem is equivalently to
find an Epsilon approximate maximum
inner product given us inut a bunch of
vectors with half ones and half
zeros okay so now let me convert that
into an attention Matrix here's the
attention problem again
um and the the idea at first is quite
simple we're just going to make our q
and K matrices exactly consist of these
inputs to the maximum in our product
problem so we'll concatenate together
we'll make Q transpose be a a d byn
Matrix which is all the X Prime vectors
K transpose will be all the Y Prime
vectors um and we're going to multiply
them by B the the magnitude that's going
to be important to us so these are m
matrices in whose entries are either
zeros or B's
or and they're n byd
matrices okay so now what is how is the
attention Matrix defined well it's IJ
entry is is exactly this e to the power
of uh the in product between the I
column of Q transpose and the I the J
column of K transpose which is d^ 2times
the inter product of x i Prime and Y J
Prime divided by d uh so in our case we
need to distinguish to solve maximum in
our product we need to distinguish
between two things the first is that all
of them have small inner product all
their inner products are most T * d uh
which means that in the attention Matrix
all the entries are at most X like e to
the^ of T * b ^
2 pluging T * D into this okay and I'm
going to call that that number T Tilda
this is like an important threshold for
us so case one all the entries are at
most this number T Tilda and the second
case is that there exists an entry where
the the inner product of the I and J
vectors are at least 1 plus Epsilon time
T * d uh which means the I F3 of the
attention Matrix is at least e to the 1
plus Epsilon time T * b ^ 2 and if we
pick B to be a big enough constant Time
s root log n so that like Epsilon time D
* T * B square is like 10 * log n let's
say then this is like way bigger than T
Tilda this is like n the 10 * T Tilda
this is where the square root log n is
going to be important for our lower
bound okay so this is how we construct
our matrices and now R let me just
remind you our goal is to distinguish
between the two cases first case is that
all the entries of the attention Matrix
are between zero and tlda and the second
is that a has a way bigger entry that's
like n the 10 * t
Tilda um
so now if we were doing kernel density
estimation instead of attention we'd
basically be done so if we were if we
could compute a Time V instead of D
inverse time a * V then we could pick V
to be just like the all ones Vector like
the all ones vector and then a bunch of
zeros for the rest so when you do a
times V it computes the row sums of the
attention Matrix and if one of the
entries is you can just check if any of
the entries is is bigger than n the 10
time T Tilda because if we're in the
first case all the entries are going to
be at most n * T Tilda so there's a very
big gap between how big the entries
would be however in our case for
attention we don't get a Time V we get D
inverse time A Time B and you know
exactly the definition of d says that D
inverse time a times the all ones Vector
is always going to give us the all ones
Vector so this this D inverse scaling
sort of exactly messes up this approach
okay but we're we can uh modify what's
going on just a tiny bit so that the
inverse doesn't impact what's going on
too much and and we can still make this
approach succeed so here's here's the
idea I'm just going to increase the
dimensions of Q and K by constant
factors I'll make them like this now so
q and K uh here they are like the top
left blue parts are exactly what they
were before but I'm just adding in D
more uh rows and N More sorry D more
columns and N More rows where I'm
putting it in Q like a bunch of bunch of
ones on the right side and in K I'm
putting you know zeros in the top part
and ones in the bottom part okay so I'm
just I'm just increasing the dimensions
by constant factors like this uh what's
what's the point of this well now if you
look at what's the I row of the
attention Matrix the first n of the
entries are exactly the same as what
they were before like like the these
ones and zeros don't impact the first n
Columns of the attention Matrix at all
but the second nend columns are all the
same number exponential and b^ squ
because they're they're just inner
products of ones and ones okay uh so and
and if B is the big enough constant
times root log n then this is some some
number that's n to the power of some big
constant um so in
particular all the entries of D inverse
now are nearly identical to each other
they're all all the entries of D are
like within a factor of two of each
other because you have n entries that
are as big as possible and then n other
entries that are like between zero and
that value all the entries of all the
row sums of this new attention Matrix
are the same within a factor of two all
the entries of D inverse are about the
same as within a factor of two but if we
pick V to be the vector that's ones for
the first half and zeros for the second
half then a * V is like the same as
before so now D is not hurting us too
much it's just scaling things by a
factor factor of two but still like
before we're looking for an entry that's
like n the N times bigger than the the
other entries so this will we'll still
be able to detect the the close par okay
this the the trick to make it work for
attention Okay so that's that's the
lower bound and where the square root
log in comes from here um let me tell
you about the algorithm
now so in the algorithm okay we we want
to solve this problem in in nearly
linear time and here's our here's our
plan what we're going to do we we were
again we want to implicitly make use of
this a attention Matrix a Without Really
explicitly Computing all its entries so
our goal is going to be to compute a low
rank approximation of a we're going to
try to compute matrices L and R that are
n by M for some M that's way smaller
than n uh such that L * R transpose is
approximately equal to a I'll call it a
til Duff L * r
transpose okay why why is if we do this
let me show you why we can do the whole
attention quite quickly well first of
all we can approximate D so D It's
supposed to be you take a times the all
one vector and then uh turn that into a
diagonal matrix we could instead compute
a Tilda times an all one vector and turn
that into a diagonal matrix and you can
do that quickly by first multiplying R
transpose times all one vector in n * m
time and then multiplying L times that
in n * m time so you can compute an
approximation to D that I'll call D
Tilda quickly and then you can compute
the output instead of outputting D
inverse time A Time V we'll output D
inverse Tilda time a Tilda time V and
again by breaking up a till into L * R
and doing first R transpose times V then
L times that then D inverse TAA times
that you can also do this in n * m time
um so so if we have this this
decomposition the whole thing takes n *
m time um and I'll I'll spare you some
calculations but it's the vi say to have
a Tilda be an approximation of a where
each entry has to be like at most
Epsilon over two away from what it's
supposed to be and then you kind of get
two error propagations one from a Tilda
one from D Tilda and the the whole thing
will still be within Epson of what
you're trying to Output at the end and
we need M to be n to the little o of one
so that this algorithm runs in time n
the 1 plus little of one so this is the
plan how do we find these matrices L and
R now well the key tool is going to be
polinomial approximations of of the
exponential function um so here's here's
the what I mean by that so so the in
these uh approximation there's two
parameters there's B the like interval
you want to approximated over and
Epsilon how much error you're willing to
tolerate um and we know that that for
any B and Epsilon there's a polinomial
that uh for any X between like minus b^2
and b^2 which it will be the range that
we care about uh approximate it with
with an additive Epsilon and it has
degree this uh the maximum of two
terms U okay one of those B * square
root log one over Epsilon and others
more like log one over Epsilon over some
log log factors and actually
interestingly the like the the details
of what these log log factors are was
only nailed down recently in this this
work last year and it's going to turn
out to be really really important for
our algorithm so uh yeah we'll see in a
couple of slides but figuring out what
these log logs were will will turn out
to be important for making our our
algorithm be fast enough uh and this is
this is tight we have matching upper and
lower bounds that that this is get okay
so let me how are we going to use this
so the the idea this is often called the
poly poomi method and algorithm design
um so oh
yes does
coefficients uh yeah I yeah it could
matter in principle here the
coefficients are they're all polylog in
the relevant parameter so it doesn't
impact it in principle it could be
important but it it turns out they're
small here yeah
question
okay um okay right so our goal is to
compute these matrices l andr so that LR
transpose approximates
a um okay so here's how we're going to
do it so let me introduce a little bit
of notation so let's let me write Q subi
for the I row of Q and K subj for the J
row of K these are vectors of length D
like order log n um and the IJ entry of
the attention Matrix is supposed to be e
to the inner product between Qi and KJ
divided by D okay so what I'm going to
do is let P be the polinomial I just
mentioned the polinomial of degree G
that exilon approximates e to the X on
this interval between minus b^2 and b^2
and I'm going to my my approximation to
the the attention Matrix is just going
to be defined exactly the same way but
instead of X I'm going to write P so I'm
going to use my polinomial in the
definition of the Matrix um so you can
see like immediately this this this a
Tilda is a good uh entry-wise
approximation of a it follows directly
from the fact that P is a good
approximation of e to the X um but what
we need to do now is compute these
matrices L and R so that L * R transpose
is equal to this a Tilda Matrix okay and
here's here is the idea so P evaluated
at you know the inner product of Qi and
KJ we can expand it out like this what
the inner product means um we're going
to think about this it's a polom in two
D variables like the D entries of Qi and
the D entries of
KJ um it's degree is G the degree we
just talked about because it's we're
plugging a linear polinomial into a
degree G
polinomial um and the M the dimension
we're going to get is going to end up
being the number of monomials when you
expand this thing out which you can do
some some counting argument and see it's
2D plus G choose G monomials this this
will have when you expand it out
okay so remember our goal is we want to
make these L and R matrices so for each
Qi we want to make a vector Li of length
M and for each KJ we want to make a
vector RJ of length M so that the inner
product of Li and RJ should equal to the
polom evaluated at the inner product of
Qi and
KJ um and we'll do this by just
expanding out this polom up here uh in
terms of its monomials so here's an
example where I've I've expanded a polom
in terms of some monomials and the the
trick is that we can we can write this
as just the inner product of two
vectors where in the first Vector we're
going to put like the Q part of each
monomial and in the second part Vector
we're going to put the K part of each
monomial so when you entry-wise multiply
like the first entry of the first Matrix
in the first sorry the first entry of
the first vector and the first entry of
the second Vector you exactly get the
first monomial and so on when you take
the inner product between these two
vectors it's exactly evaluating the
polom uh so these two vectors evaluate
the polinomial but importantly the first
one depends only on Qi and the second
Vector depends only on KJ so these are
exactly the Li and RJ vectors that we
needed each entry can be computed very
quickly you just multiply together some
entries of the Q and the K vectors and
the length is the number of monomials in
the polinomial which is this binomial
coefficient that's that's how we make
these these
matrices L and
R okay so then what's the running time
we get at the end well Alo what I just
showed you is roughly you can solve the
problem in times in time n times M where
m is this binomial coefficient um so let
me remind you what all these things are
G is the degree of our polinomial
approximating e to the X which is this
weird expression um and what are the
other things D is like order log n uh
Epsilon I'm going to think of as one
over poly poly n okay so now now we can
plug in some things into these
expressions and see what we get well
first of all if B is small L of square
root log n then the degree G is also
going to be small o of squ root log n
okay the first term is like small root o
of square root log n time sare Root log
n the second one is log n divid by log
of log n over small o of log again oh I
think sorry I think there's supposed to
be a two here but okay anyway
the but both both of the terms are small
low of log n so the degree G is small
low of log n so m is like log n choose
small low of log n which is n to the
little low of one and you get a final
running time that's indeed n to the one
plus little L of one
time um and by contrast you can see once
B is just a bit bigger like some big
enough constant square root of log n
then then this m
is like G is now uh some constant times
log n and now m is like some constant
choose Times log n choose another
constant times log n it's really
polinomial in N uh so this algorithmic
approach no longer works when B just
gets to some constant Time Square Root
log n and furthermore by the lower bound
we talked about before actually assuming
Seth there's no algorithm that can be
into the two in this case not only can
this polinomial not beat it but assuming
Seth no algorithm could beat it yeah so
your polom I'm inent was this lock
factor in the second term in denominator
yeah that's right I sorry there's I
think there's supposed to be a two here
so that that this makes the difference
between this being super constant or a
constant just to make sure I'm
understanding if like you said you know
if that term wasn't there then G would
have degree
um I guess log in and then this whole
method would not go through it yeah
exactly yes this like log log Factor
ends up being important because it like
shows up in the exponent and what m is
yeah so abson one over pomal is that
important or um okay so my understanding
is when you when you like apply this
attention in these in these Transformer
models there's like kind of a polom
number of of units you're applying it to
so you need like if you want to
accumulate all the
errors for your results yeah yeah
exactly if the if the error smaller then
uh like both the degrees get smaller I
think I think
there's certainly certainly uh the
degree gets smaller and you get a faster
algorithm I think there's probably more
straightforward things you could do if
you want
small like something like random
sampling of
coordinates
yeah
okay
um so I think I have like 10 minutes
left about let me talk a little bit
about yeah where where this degree
actually comes from because it's kind of
the the PowerHouse behind the whole
algorithm and I just claimed it without
telling you anything about it um right
so I I told you you know there's a
polinomial of degree this for exponen
for for approximating e to the x uh
where does it come from um and the the
main idea is is to make use of a nice
family of polinomial uh called Chev pols
so Chev pols this this is a family of
pols like for any degree D there's a d
CHF polinomial they have lots of
equivalent definitions one nice one is
this trigonometric definition that when
you plug in cosine of theta it gives
cosine of D * Theta and scal Factor um
but if it's not maybe it's not clear to
you depending on how much like high
school trig you remember that this is a
polinomial you can you can equivalently
Define in this nice recursive way uh
where it's very clear it's a polom and
you check by induction that these two
definitions are equival to each other um
so what do these pols look like here's
here's an example of the the 10th Chev
polinomial so like between minus one and
one they're they're wiggling up and down
like a kind of like a cosine because of
the trig definition and then outside of
that interval they blow up like a
polinomial hot too um so the the one
really nice thing about Chevy Chef pols
that makes them useful here is they have
really nice extremal properties so for
example it's known that among all the
pols of degree D such that in this
interval between minus one and one
they're always bounded by okay the
scaling Factor 2 the one minus d uh the
Chev polinomial is the one that
maximizes the value of the polom for
every Point that's outside the interval
from minus one to one so like here you
can see the pols but I I rescaled it by
the two to the D minus one factor so
between minus one and one it's bounded
between minus one and one because of the
trig property but then anywhere to the
right or to the left of this box the
Chev polinomial is the one that gets the
biggest possible
value okay so why is why is this
relevant to approximating exponentials
well so let me let me give an example of
how we can use this extremal property to
actually show a lower bound on the
degree to approximate uh e to the minus
X okay so here's here's like a a picture
of e to the minus X and if we had a
polinomial that was going to approximate
this it would at least have to have two
properties the first is that over here
in the tail uh it can't be more than
Delta away from from e to the minus X so
over here to the right it has to stay
within this red box and then all the way
to the left it has to get close to to
one like e to the zero so to the right
it has to stay bounded within this box
and to the left it has to get quite
large close to one um and so
you you can check first of all what's
the minimum degree of a Chev Chev
polinomial that achieves these two just
these two properties you can do some
work and see that it's btimes log squ
root of log one over Delta um and so
because the Chev polinomial is the
minimum degree polinomial that satisfies
these two properties that gives a lower
bound right away that the degree to
approximate e to the minus X has to also
be at least
bot log one over Delta so this is like
you can you can pretty quickly use Chev
polinomial to get lower bounds on the
degree required it turns out um chbby
Chev polinomial for this kind of Reason
are also useful for for the upper bounds
so how is it that we go about
approximating e to the minus x with Pol
nomials maybe the kind of the first idea
is you would you would just write out a
tailor series for e to the minus X and
truncate it um and you can do this and
it gives a decent degree de
approximation but uh an idea that turns
out to work better is to trunk the Chev
series instead so you do a change of
basis instead of writing it out in terms
of monomials as a series in terms of
monomials you write it out as a series
in terms of Chev pols and you truncate
that polinomial instead and it turns out
to work better much more quickly so
here's an example of just approximating
it with degree four like here's the the
tailor expansion looks like this and the
chubby Chev expansion looks like this
it's like wiggling up and down like a
Chev polinomial does um and you can see
even in this small case like the the
chubby Chev polinomial already gets like
one fifth of the error of the tailor
expansion so even very quickly these
chubby Chev polinomial are important for
approximating
exponentials um and you can you can
prove more generally like if if we had
any function at all we we wrote this you
it's sort of a a well-known fact in in
polinomial approximation theory that
chbby shf series truncations work very
well for approximating functions so if
you had any function at all that you
write as a series in terms of chubby
chef pols and you let P be its best
possible approximation not necessarily
coming from chbf polinomial then you can
both upper and lower bound how good the
approximation has to be in terms of the
coefficients in the chbby Chev Series so
the the upper bound just comes from if
you did that CH chbby Chev truncation
then because each of these rescaled
chabby shift polinomial is always at
most one you just do a triangle in
equality and you get this upper bound
the lower bound uh you have to do a
little bit of work because like the the
CHF polinomial can interfere with each
other a little bit but if you do like an
appropriate L2 analysis you you can show
a lower bound that looks like this also
and in particular if these coefficients
in the Chevy Chev series Decay quickly
enough then the upper bound and lower
bound here are very very close to each
other it roughly says that like the d+1
coefficient is is really the one that
matters and you can you can do a bit of
work and so that for exponentials they
do Decay quickly and you can even
improve this Bound for in the special
case of exponentials and uh this is the
idea behind how to how to get the tight
degree for for the
ex okay
thanks any
questions
hey uh do you think your harness result
continue to hold if you take abson to be
small
constant I think currently the harness
result hope for abson to be like one or
poly poly right but uh this thing is
like continue to hold
when oh epson's a Conant like
uh uh probably I mean I think like the
the polinomial method would actually
give a
f maybe actually it's not so
[Applause]
clear I I think the lower bound oh it
probably needs something like one yeah
actually I I I suspect it really needs
Epsilon to at least be one over n to
some particular constant uh I I think
for lower error than this there probably
are faster algorithms not using
polinomial method but using like random
sampling and hashing and things like
this but I think the problem is you take
a exponential you take e to that every
entry yeah yeah but there's like um so
like there are going to be other talks
in this Workshop about using like
hashing methods for kernel density
estimation that work better for small
like they usually have polinomial
dependence on Epsilon but then worse
dependence on D but I think if you use
those kinds of approaches like like a
totally different algorithmic approach
it actually works well when epsilon's
like a
constant
[Applause]
nice talk uh so I have question on both
the algorithm side and the lower bound
so for the algorithm I mean like right
now it's to me at least it seems like
you need every entry to be like less
than a square root of login or something
but let's say most of the entries are
guarante to be like less than square
root of login but some of the entries
could be bigger can you modify your
algorithm to still work there or it's
not known yeah uh depending on the
details most likely like maybe you could
just correct the specific entries where
the polinomial approximation you know
it's going to be wrong or you could
there's like a in multipole methods you
kind of partition up space into a bunch
of of of cubes and then you you like say
the polinomial works well between Pairs
of cubes and uh assume there can't be
too many cubes that points are in and
things like this there there are tricks
for dealing depending on exactly what
the
details sounds good so on the lower
bound side also it's like so you have
like half of the entries like at least
like um like bigger than like square
root of login or something so um so in
general like let's say if only like
little of in square entries are like
bigger than square root of login or
something what do you expect like do you
think there'll be a better algorithm or
you think there could be a lower bound
like uh Pro probably I mean you
could I see like yeah so maybe then you
you like partition up the Matrix into
the sparse part and the small entries
part and and can separately deal with
both them I I guess there's there's
algorithms you
could thank
you
question thanks Josh once again
uh there's now a 30 minute break until
the last Talk of the morning